>> WHAT IS YOUR POSITION ON THAT
TONIGHT.
>> I CAN TELL THIS IS THE
POSITION OF EVERY UKRAINIAN
BECAUSE WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE DIE EVERY DAY.
MORE THAN 200 SCHOOLS.
SO FAR THE WEST IS VERY WEAK IT
LOOKS LIKE EVERYBODY IS SCARED
OF PUTIN.
THE SANCTIONS IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR AND NO OIL AND GAS.
JUST COMPARED TO THE SAME OF
CALVIN KLEIN LED THE RUSSIAN
MARKET AND SAID THEY WILL NOT
SELL GENES THERE BUT WE CAN KEEP
THE REST OF THE CLOSE, THAT IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
THE WORLD.
ALSO WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
BANKING SANCTIONS THAT WAS
PROMISED WITH THE RUSSIAN BANKS.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY WERE SWITCHED
OUT OF 300 BANKS THAT ARE THERE
IN RUSSIA.
WE KEEP WATCHING HOW THE WORLD
IS TRYING TO PROTECT THE ECONOMY
NOT TO STEP IN AND EVEN
ECONOMICS OF RUSSIA.
ALSO IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESPONSE
OF THE MILITARY, WE DON'T ASK TO
BE PROTECTED.
WE DON'T NEED SOLDIERS TO COME
UP AND FIGHT FOR UKRAINE, THEY
KEPT ASKING THE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM THAT CAN PROTECT OUR SKY
BECAUSE MISSILES AND BOMBS ARE
THE KEY PROBLEM FOR US THAT ARE
KILLING THOUSANDS OF CIVILIANS.
IMPLEMENTING HIS STRATEGY, HIS
STRATEGY IS SIMPLE TO KILL AS
MANY CIVILIANS AS HE CAN AND PUT
US AT THE TABLE FOR
NEGOTIATIONS.
WE HAD BIG CITY SURROUNDED BY
THE RUSSIAN ARMY RIGHT NOW FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITY OF MARIUPOL
400,000 PEOPLE WHICH IS HALF OF
THE SIZE OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
TOTALLY SURROUNDED BY THE
RUSSIAN ARMY PEOPLE, WOMEN,
CHILDREN TO GET OUT.
NO SAFE QUARTER.
THEY CANNOT BE ENFORCED BECAUSE
RUSSIANS ARE SHOOTING CIVILIANS
AND PEOPLE ARE STARVING TO DEATH
AT THE MOMENT IN THE CITY AND
CANNOT GET OUT.
THAT IS WHAT EVERY UKRAINIAN AND
THE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ASKING
FOR THE SUPPORT THAT WAS
PROMISED FOR US.
20 YEARS AGO WE GAVE UP OUR
NUKES, WHAT ARE THE LARGEST
COUNTRY WITH THE LARGEST NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
WE GAVE IT UP FOR THE PROMISE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE
PROTECTION FOR THE UNITED
STATES, THE UNITED KINGDOM IN
RUSSIA IF ANYTHING HAPPENED.
THIS IS NOT HAPPENING.
WE CANNOT EVEN GET YOU TO DO THE
SANCTIONS ON OIL AND GAS WHICH
IS THE MAIN INCOME.
STEVE: THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING SO FORCEFULLY CLEAR.
WHAT IS SO INFURIATING ABOUT THE
LAST POINT, PUTTING THE SINKS
INTO PLACE AND RAMPING UP U.S.
SUPPLY, WE REPLACE RUSSIAN OIL
GAS WITH AMERICAN OIL AND GAS
WOULD HELP AMERICA AND WE ARE
NOT DOING THAT.
THAT I